I could not sleep at all last night
because I was so excited for today that
I'm going to a women's retreat and the
reason that I'm so excited is because we
often hear on minimalism channels about
Dearing our physical spaces but what we
often don't hear is that the most
important decluttering we can do is
what's in here it's our mental spiritual
and emotional baggage and we all carry
it because we're all broken and flawed
individuals in our own ways so if you
want to know how to live minimally but
live in abundance that it's minimalism
with a holistic lens that approaches it
from the inside out be sure to subscribe
for my channel for more positive and
uplifting content